[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
i just wanted to make this quick video
to announce some
of the most exciting harry potter news
that we've had in a very
long time a harry potter tv show
we haven't had a new harry potter movie
in a very long time
and though the fantastic beasts films
have satisfied my craving for new harry
potter content
to some degree true harry potter content
is what i want
and i think it's what the fans want
according to numerous new sites as well
as the hollywood reporter
a harry potter live-action tv series is
in early development at hbo max
sources tell the hollywood reporter that
executives at the warner media backed
streamer have engaged in multiple
conversations with potential writers
exploring various ideas that would bring
the beloved property to television
sources say broad ideas have been
discussed as part of the early stage
exploratory meetings
expanding the world of harry potter
remains a top priority for hbo max and
warner bros
which along with creator jk rowling
controls wright's the property
harry potter is one of warner's most
valuable pieces of ip
news that talks are underway for harry
potter tv series
should come as no surprise given the
value of the franchise to warner bros
rolling seven book series was adapted as
eight feature films
that grossed more than seven billion
worldwide warner
also have the fantastic beasts prequel
films with the third installment coming
in 2022
and two more coming afterwards it's sort
of an unwritten unspoken thing that fans
have always wanted a harry potter show
and there's even a popular harry potter
related meme
which originated on reddit some time ago
that discusses hbo and harry potter
together
however one thing important to note is
that things are still
very early on preliminary discussions
have only just started
while it's news that executives at hbo
max and warner
are engaged in meetings to find a writer
and pitch for a harry potter tv series
no writers or talent are currently
attached as the conversations are still
in the extremely early stages
and no deals have been made the plans
for harry potter tv series
should be seen as a rightful extension
of the property at a time when warner
media
like other conglomerates is prioritizing
its streaming service
hbo max launched last year and is the
home of all of the company's most
valuable intellectual property at this
stage it's hard to say what these shows
are going to be about
but if i had to guess then they're going
to be prequels the origin stories of the
characters that we know and love
in this way requesting some of the
actors could be achievable
depending on how this was approached
what do you guys think of this news
i think that if it's done well and
rowling is more involved than she was
with the cursed child
then very good things could be on the
horizon that's it for this video
i will elaborate further in another
video later this week
until next time remember differences of
habits and language are nothing at all
if our aims are identical and our hearts
are open
[Music]
you